like I get really like especially if
it's Veronica man like if they say
something about her like you know and I
have a feeling people who are watching
this video are probably gonna say some
[ __ ] just to try to get trying to
provoke me or something and I was just
gonna say you might want to cut this
phone yeah maybe maybe this is ross rasa
no matter what it is I rarely rarely
react anymore at all anything they say
and they just get blocked because I
realize is only food it's only feel them
yeah the only it's weird when you see
haters that like you're like damn this
hater watch so many of my videos just to
hate on me you know and and it's like
why would I want it's like I don't mind
walking because I'm like not because i'm
a [ __ ] or something it's just why would
i want to drag such a negative energy
towards my channel of someone who is not
doing anything supportive and
pointlessly trying to take me down like
it's like there's no point in having it
I get it doesn't do good and it's I'm
there for the subscribers on there for
the people who love the channel not for
these guys who don't want anything to do
with it so you know it's like this is
pointless so yeah [ __ ] you're gonna
get blocked if you keep up this [ __ ]
anyway man um okay it's been one hour I
should probably get going because it's
my birthday in a few hours and I have
friends coming by Oh buddy now 25 only
ah that's it's just amazing gun 38
you're 38 yes I thought you were like 29
this is [ __ ] weird innit I hope I
look as good as you when I'm 38 holy
[ __ ] man that it's [ __ ] insane all my
friends are younger to me food weird it
all over but that's so funny now I got
friends who are older and friends who
are younger I got I got friends all
across the board and but i gotta will be
the boat by knows the majority they're
all you know you're probably my second
oldest friend okay
that's funny man no I really thought you
were like in your early 20s like late
20s yeah it ranges they always be to
think it's early or mid or they think
it's mid or late but it's always 20s
somewhere do you reveal that ever like
on your channel I've said it a few
videos okay I only really looks like
what yeah lady why no I amber um I was
kind of flirting with this girl online
in woman and uh uh I brought up my age
and I asked her was that okay apparently
she didn't know but she she was always
talking about this specific person that
was much older than me that she had a
crush on and you know when I told her my
age she was like um and then I feel old
something well you always talking about
him she was like yeah he's that's you
know my elbow [ __ ] that go with you if
you're giving him a [ __ ] pass just
cuz he's a celebrity I don't want to
tell who he is because if I do it'll
kind of pinpoint she'll know she is then
I think she listened right now she'll
know she is now she know wow false trail
markers [ __ ] that shiner muff pretty or
not you're willing to [ __ ] with me
before you knew my age then it shouldn't
be no you know now yeah problem most
girls actually don't have a problem by a
jiffy they're in their 20s yeah I mean
being an older got older guy doesn't
tend to bother women usually at least
out here I noticed I think like 21
though you know but still this dudes in
his forties and [ __ ] yeah oh I filled
out with him oh you [ __ ] you yeah I knew
a girl who has started dating a guy in
his 40s when she was 19 and they dated
for like four years yeah yeah that's
fine you know I had a girl Lucia and she
knows who she is the I I was me and her
we chitchat jajajaja smile
over in Australia and she uh she asked
me could I see myself dating a 19 year
old and you know she was 19 well in the
way she looked me and she can away she
did her makeup than anything she didn't
look like that I thought she was at
least 23 and I was like well if her head
was on screwed on right her mind was
right I guess so you're out of your
legal you know so now she's actually
dating an Olympian oh yeah I guess you
like celebrity Wow an Olympian huh yeah
you could be an Olympian um you could be
an Olympian probably I used to run track
when I was younger you know a few shots
of steroids in the butt yeah did you
really used to do that no no no no no se
a lot of I'm not saying they all do
balazs Olympian roids that's actually
the reason why I stopped okay I ran in
high school and I wanted to run in
college that I've never read this
article by this guy who is talking about
the basically the dark secrets you don't
know about a lot of Olympians the fact
that almost all from on steroids and I
refuse to use it you know it makes a
popped it out epic I need a more
talented athlete you know but I just I
welcome frisky the bad that can come the
hell would the glory of my help oh oh
yeah man health is long-term and you
know good I don't want to be I'm
starting to get concerned like I got my
blood pressure check today and I was
like [ __ ] its high and like that now
like really concerned me especially with
heart disease running in my family so
I'm like really now i'm trying to get
paranoid and so um i'm trying to take it
more I'm really trying this time to like
get it under control so yeah I mean I
haven't talked about the food [ __ ] in my
therapy sometimes like it's like I don't
get it some I'll go three days and then
suddenly it's just like I need it
or you're going girl yeah but no I once
did three days without soda and then I
noticed I was like I wasn't even
thinking about it I just started getting
a headache and I was getting lightheaded
and I was sleepy and then I looked up
soda withdrawals is I didn't even know
that was a thing and then I was like
holy [ __ ] it's everything I'm going
through and they make sure enough once I
drink a soda I started feeling fine
again so right yeah man there's a lot of
bad habits I got a [ __ ] break with my
health because I'm like I'm really
concerned but yeah it's a process a by
Dave babies and we are I eat more
watermelon out well just think about
this you don't want to keel over why you
own on Veronica making sweet love I
heard this she can't get out from
underneath there is no y overdue CBO i
like to say on the fastest fattest [ __ ]
the three apps in my life fastest
satisfied but you said you know how to
[ __ ] so you got now you gotta be the
phenomenal fast as bad as [ __ ] yeah yeah
daniels1 fantastic fantastic read from
well that is Fanta Fanta forever we'll
figure it out later but yeah my brother
is coming by in a little bit so I gotta
go hang out with him alright good talk
to you except atomic party yeah and I'll
be out in arm I'll be out of new york
sometime in September's so i'll let you
know alright cool alright see you buddy
I'm flp lyric 1 million subscriber yes I
need a natural but